sticky spiced chicken wings
jack
give us a hand please
why
because it's your favorite yeah chicken
wings
okay
all right let's start off with the
marinade tamarind paste in first
all that into there all of that yeah all
of that okay
good
so two tablespoons of palm sugar please
is that like heated sugar um it's a
really good question here it's a natural
palm sugar
and it's perfect for marinades how many
wings do you think you've eaten so far
at the age of 13. oh oh i eat
probably 50 a year
50 years yeah something like that a nice
sprinkle of chilli flakes depends how
hot you like them
oh i love them hot hot uh don't forget
the girls you know they start
complaining when you get them too hot
how come you love hot food
um
i don't know i really love hot food so
in there we've got palm sugar
tamarind paste chili flakes some garlic
one nice tablespoon
of fish sauce please
this is looking really good isn't it and
then a couple of tablespoons of oil the
marinade
in how nice a little taste
not your finger jack
that's really good right wings in get
your hands in there and start rubbing in
the marinade please okay
so the secret now is to coat
the chicken wings and all that marinade
yeah yeah
how long do you leave them in here do
you know what
the longer the better
cover that
oh my glim film wash your hands
excellent
good job
ideally marinate your wings overnight
but half an hour will be enough to get
the flavors going
[Applause]
right so they've marinated now
if you take the tray out people
bottom one thank you and then we're
gonna put some tinfoil on there thank
you
so
pop that in half
it stops them from sticking and
that will stop
the wings from burning so from there
get them really dipped in that marinade
and try and get the wing like that and
just sort of scoop it
no like that so get that really nice
glaze on there
and then just
yeah
so that garlic will roast
and we've got all those wings
beautifully
done i can make them ready for the oven
170 25 to 30 minutes
yep good man
excellent
nice it's hot wings are in
right
to go with my ultimate southeast asian
dinner rice cooked in homemade thai
green curry paste
for the easy green curry paste roughly
chopped coriander
lemongrass
green chilies
lime leaf shallots
garlic and ginger
add lug of oil and blitz
the paste takes minutes to make but
it'll keep for up to 10 days if covered
with oil and stored in a sealed jar in
the fridge
to awaken the flavors lime roll to
release the juice
next season with salt and pepper and
blend into a smooth paste
heat the paste until aromatic
add in cooled or leftover rice i love
using fragrant jasmine rice but your
standard long grain rice is great too
[Music]
when thoroughly heated through
serve
thai green curry paste is so easy to
make so with rice like this it's
incredible but simply add to chicken
fish or veg to create a fantastic meal
in minutes
right now for the green beans
beans in
uh bring the water to the ball what's
the first thing i should put in there
beans
salt salt so nice pinch of salt in there
yeah
so make an amazing dressing two nine
tablespoons yep of a crunchy peanut
butter please why is it crunchy it'll
give it texture
and it'll be nice and sort of chunky
green beans in okay got the rice green
beans
we're gonna blotch them for two two and
a half minutes what does blanching
actually mean blanching means sort of
part cooking
okay i'm gonna blanch them in boiling
water yeah and then finish them
in the pan use the back of the spoon a
little bit easier
a teaspoon of brown sugar
and she goes
nice
is that a little bit too thick
maybe yeah it is let's put a little
touch more soy sauce in there let it
down
yeah yeah much better
touch some vinegar nice
i'm going to get a pan on now
for my beans
so
i'll taste did you taste it
it's so good oh man
hmm wow so have you got the garlic like
that i'm going to slice the garlic
down like this
keep the knife
nice and flat
that way you'll slice through it
but take your time don't worry about the
speed and technique right first just cut
it in half okay
your fingers good and then lay the flat
side down so it's nice and sturdy and
that nail there
it's not out like that it's just guiding
the knife so you can never cut yourself
like that
good i'll drain the beans
nice a little
tablespoon
of oil
get the pan nice and hot
and throw the garlic in people
good
nice
mmm so first smell that already is that
lily
so give that
a little toss
so when you toss it push it down
push away and pull back
okay have a little go
push it down and gently
take your time
nice
so
push down
and pull back up that's it nice
so it's getting nice and golden brown
green beans i've drained
and they go in now to the garlic
combination of green beans
okay with the rice
i don't know it's not about
oh wow
i want you now
spoon the dressing release and she goes
nice
how delicious does that look wow what's
daddy's policy at home no waste no waste
no waste but
now
smell that now
oh wow
it doesn't smell like green beans it
smells like what is this oh thanks
how nice is that
lovely amazing right
that's the rice that's the green beans
[Music]
now i want you to sprinkle some toasted
sesame seeds on top please
nice and generous with a sesame seed
i'll give the beans a little bit of a
crunch
now
all that's left
for your favorites to come out don't
those beans smell amazing
jack look at those beauties one for me
one for you three for me
one for you
i'd like you to sprinkle some spring
onions
on top please
nice and generous
you transformed a very cheap and
cheerful chicken wing
yeah right you take them over please do
not drop them okay jack let's go but
nice
this is my ultimate simple southeast
asian dinner
sticky spicy chicken wings thai green
curry rice and fantastic beans with
chili peanut dressing guaranteed to get
the fussiest of eaters into greens
made with fantastic chicken cooked using
a classic but simple french technique
this is my ultimate home-cooked french
dinner
first job my chicken fricker say
tilly
would you mind helping daddy with the
chicken fricassee please
we're going to start off
with browning
all
the chicken off nicely pan on get that
nice and hot
what i want you to do for me first
is to season
the chicken with salt and pepper please
thank you
so
that's on one side then we turn the
chicken over so we season it on the
other side
salt
good girl and pepper
nice
now this is almost like a chicken stew
okay
what's that there
[Music]
um time time
good girl what's that one there
that one's real that's right rosalie
and because this is quite a rustic
french dish
we don't need to chop everything
so you get the garlic
and you just bash it like that now smell
mmm
that's right
so that's nice and hot
put a tablespoon of olive oil in there a
couple of plugs
one two
good girl put the chicken in it
and you lay away
you're like nice and brown i'm getting
good at this you are
skin side down
so we got the color on the skin now i
just want you to cut the mushrooms in
half the belly please
okay these are chestnut mushrooms there
are lots of different types of mushrooms
out there there are lots and lots of
different types of mushrooms
one of my favorites
is the giro mushroom i like
mushrooms that are a bit bigger than
this and um some dinners with mum we cut
out the middle put pesto and cheese in
it and then we bake them uh-oh
i want you to sprinkle the pancetta over
the chicken please
good girl
nice put the mushrooms in not yet
because i'm gonna get some color on the
chicken first
okay
and
as that
pancetta starts to cook down
it puts a really nice flavor on the
chicken
so we're sort of soating everything okay
right garlic in please
good girl just throw them in
and i want you to sprinkle the mushrooms
on top of that good girl
and then there's the rosemary you can
get your fingers like that and you pull
it down
you take it all off
hold it
put it down good girl so now you've got
the nice little rosemary sprigs and we
do the same with the thyme now the thyme
flour is a little bit smaller what
different flavors do they give so the
thyme is a little bit sweeter
okay and the rosemary a little bit more
savoury which ones you like i like them
both because they both get a nice smell
don't they so bay leaf in
i'd like you to put that rosemary
and thyme
in there please
lovely sprinkle it over right i'd like
you to stand back now because we're
going to flambe this i do not want to
get those little slippers caught on fire
what are the names rampa and
judy judah nice okay great ready
yeah
in with the brandy
and then just tilt the pan gently
whoa
whoa
how cool is that magical
beautiful bit like a cauldron all the
cognac has been flambe so there's no raw
alcohol anywhere so we've got a really
nice deep rich flavor i'm going to add
my chicken stock you know rampo likes
that not my slipper rump or run for the
dog ah rumple the dog well he likes
chicken stock
yes when he's a good boy he gets some he
gets it in his um with his biscuit it's
gone in like
wow really quickly simmer and reduce the
stock for around 10 minutes
now we're gonna cook the most amazing
potatoes
soda potatoes are really simple to make
and absolutely delicious start by
slicing the potatoes into finger whipped
pieces then parboil them for five to six
minutes
when you cook something like rosemary or
thyme or basil does it slowly let off
the flavor into the bottle very much so
in a hot pan add a tablespoon of goose
fat and saute the potatoes until they
turn golden
and add in shallots garlic rosemary and
thyme
that goes in
over
top
and that goose fat now is starting to
fry
the potatoes
you just leave that sat there
to complete my ultimate french dinner my
version of a classic a glorious lavender
creme caramel for dessert
the first job is the lavender sugar you
can buy this ready-made or simply add
dried edible sprigs of lavender to
caster sugar and store
you can also try this trick with vanilla
pods and cinnamon to bring new subtle
flavors to sweets and bacon
[Music]
for the creme caramel melt plain caster
sugar until it turns dark golden
pour into ramekins sprinkle with
lavender flowers and cool
now to make a simple custard gently heat
whole milk in a pan until steaming
meanwhile whisk together egg vanilla
seeds and lavender sugar until golden
and fluffy then gradually pour the hot
milk into the mix whisking continuously
until the custard is smooth and creamy
to set cook in a water bath or bamberry
a good tip is to line a roasting tin
with a cloth to stop the ramekins
jiggling around pour your custard
then boiling water around the ramekins
until halfway up the sides
then cook in a preheated oven for around
30 minutes until set
cool in the fridge
then when you're ready to serve dip the
ramekins in hot water to loosen the
creme caramel
[Music]
lavender clean caramel
[Music]
look at that chicken now
so
i'm just gonna turn the gas right down
and put the lid on
just like that but leave a little bit so
it can let out some stuff so i can let
out some steam that's right
now what i'd like to do is to chop daddy
some parsley crunch it up nicely tuck
your fingers in and take your time
[Music]
now my hands have got lots of different
flavors
all those wonderful flavors
you could almost be french
sprinkle that on there
good girl
nice
messy boku
i can tell jack's going to love this is
he
looks the nest doesn't it
smells
delicious look at that
i could smell that even before you took
the lid off let's kill my darling
good job by the way thank you i can't
wait for the others to try it i hope
that i love it
this is my ultimate french dinner
chicken fricassee with sensational
herbie sauteed potatoes and lavender
creme caramel the main course will be a
crispy big caesar salad but the first
job are my peanut butter and jam cookies
[Music]
start with a cookie dough simply combine
muscovado sugar peanut butter and butter
until light and fluffy
then add your egg a splash of milk
vanilla seeds and beat again until
smooth
sift together salt baking powder and
flour
[Music]
then mix until thoroughly combined
[Music]
in floured hands roll the cookie dough
into golf ball sizes flatten and create
an indent with your finger
fill with half jam and half peanut
butter
place the cookies on a tray lined with
baking paper and bake in a preheated
oven for 10 to 12 minutes
cool before serving
[Music]
next job main course and my take on an
iconic american salad first made almost
a century ago caesar salad is definitely
a classic but the trick to keeping
dishes like this modern and relevant is
to tweak them but not lose what made
them brilliant in the first place
here's my version for the ultimate
american lunch
my first twist is in the dressing for me
the most important part of the caesar
salad is that dressing
rich creamy slightly spicy
begin by making a basic mayonnaise
start off with the egg yolks in
just
a little spoon dijon and then
a little splash of red wine vinegar
start whisking
once you've got that nice slightly
thickened texture
drizzle in your olive oil
it should fall through
your whisk it's like a nice
thick
double cream texture
beautiful
now take the mayo to another level with
anchovies and crushed garlic now chop up
the anchovies and the garlic together
so we almost want that to be like a
really nice
puree
then grated parmesan
lemon juice that will make the
dressing
citrusy
lighter in color and then a little
splash of water
in
now all of a sudden it transforms that
mayonnaise into an amazing
delicious
light dressing
nice
next job the croutons and i like using
crusty bread for extra crunch
and just dice up
your bread
season with salt and pepper then add to
a hot pan with olive oil and fry
give that a really nice toss
as the croutons start to turn golden
simply grate on a generous amount of
parmesan cheese keep them rolling around
stop them from sticking together look at
that really nice cheesy
delicious
crouton and now
they're out
now for the fun job assembling the
caesar salad starting with romaine
lettuce
and don't slice
the lettuce
too thinly
a squeeze of lemon on with half of that
gutsy anchovy mayo dressing
saving some to coat your chicken later
then sprinkle half your croutons
give that a really nice mix
salad in
it's all beautifully dressed
add the remaining croutons and finish
with a good grating of parmesan cheese
that for me is a perfect caesar salad
however i'm gonna take it to another
level and grill a stunning chicken
breast start by preheating your griddle
pan then butterfly your chicken breast
simply slice from the thin end towards
the thick bit of the breast let the
knife do the work and literally just
open up
now that's how we butterfly a chicken
breast so therefore it will cook twice
as quick and just nice and moist in the
center
season the chicken on both sides with
salt and ground pepper
lay your chicken breast onto the grill
[Music]
never oil the grill until absolutely
ready to cook your chicken
now
turn them over
[Music]
beautiful
cook for three to four minutes on each
side until the chicken's got those
lovely stripes from the griddle which
adds a gorgeous smoky flavor whilst they
rest spoon over some of the remaining
anchovy dressing
the chicken cools down
the flavour the seasoning of the anchovy
the garlic and the pound zone seeps into
that chicken slice the chicken into
strips
wow
i serve the chicken warm in a separate
bowl so it doesn't wilt the salad just
bring the dressing
finished out with a little touch of
dressing
an american classic
i think one of the most popular salads
anywhere in the world
but it's still one of the most delicious
[Music]
when it comes to lunch this really is an
american dream a delicious caesar salad
and succulent golden griddle chicken
with peanut butter and jam cookies for
dessert
[Music]
your favorite chicken thighs first of
all
we'll turn on the grill
the reason why we're using the thighs
are you the brown meat is so it doesn't
go dry season a nice
salt pepper
olive oil
then turn them over please
come on get your hands in there good
don't worry about your nail bun
so there's no bones in there so the
chicken will cook really quickly
why do you do it skin side down skin
side down first that'll stop the chicken
from going dry and it'll get it really
nice and crispy
good
see the way it's marked the skin now
yeah got all that really nice flavor in
there as well and we'll turn them every
two or three minutes how much do you
love chicken
lots lots i'm gonna serve that some
really nice chickpeas first we're gonna
make a little dressing okay
one nice teaspoon of mustard in please
a little bit of olive oil
a touch of salt
and pepper
give that a really good mix
and then
just squeeze lots
of lemon juice in there a little taste
it's nice
that is delicious
now look at that chicken now
follow that beautiful nice and crispy as
well
turn the gas down now and leave that
chicken to griddle right let's get the
chickpeas done shall we yep
so we've got peculiar peppers so these
are roasted
smoked spanish peppers have a little
taste
i would like you to chop up the
kettleberries
you take off the
the top i'm gonna slice them in half
like that
wash your fingers
oh well okay
so these are small tequila peppers
yeah a bit sweeter there you go your
fingers please watch your fingers please
tuck them in three finger rule come on
holly
you know the three finger rule i've been
telling you that since six months old
good girl you're fast aren't he yeah in
fact you're faster than jack don't tell
him we'll get him upset
at the purpose then yes please thank you
good and then give it a little mix for
your fingers
please
love it run poles
out come on out
get out every time there's food is
always there he smells it from a mile
away
the chicken's grilling it's inside down
why is it on
skin sides out because it keeps getting
moist
keeps it really nice and moist that's
right now
we'll start the watermelon salad
watermelon
feta
cucumber
pan nice and hot
get the pecans okay and just sort of
break them up
i'm going to start slicing the
watermelon
you keep the seeds in yeah these are
fine so you just make these little boats
and go around like that
now with the toasted pecans give them a
little seasoning would you please with
pepper too um no just touch your salt
thank you roll them around and just
start to see them smoking see now turn
the gas off please
we're just gonna take half the cucumber
and give that a little peel for me
please
nuts are nicely dry roasted
take them off so from there i want you
then to slice around the seeds
and that's the watery part okay we keep
that out
wash your fingers please
nice
am i still faster than jack you are
still very fast
a lot faster than jack now
cucumber on top of the melon we'll mix
it up in a minute i'm going to give that
a nice little light seasoning a touch of
salt and a little touch of pepper please
crush those little bits pecans in there
fine
nice
next greek feta cheese
this is kind of easy isn't it
jack
that fat and lump snoring you're going
to get out hurry up mate take him out
fat lazy lump snoring his head off come
on out
so we've got that nice juicy melon the
cucumber and now the cheese we need
something to bring it to life i'll taste
that's sumac okay that is very citrusy
and we're just gonna season that
lightly
now what i want you to do is sprinkle
the pecans in there
what's that
basil mint mint
minty
you get confused with battle your
boyfriend
no daddy okay good keep it that way for
another 10 years
fresh mint over
and then
a little drizzle
of olive oil okay don't mix it yet i
know you're dying to get in there aren't
you mm-hmm and just some fresh lemon
juice
why'd you roll it it starts to release
all the juice let's now feel it
so it's less firm a little bit more
squashy
no it's all that lemon juice coming out
now what we're going to do
is just have a little taste
what do you taste
everything yummy it's fresh isn't it
so that's the salad done
next a refreshingly light dessert of
lemon and basil granita
start by putting the juice of seven
lemons
and the zest of one into a small pan
with a sprinkling of caster sugar
stir over a medium heat
until the sugar dissolves
dilute your granita mix with a little
water
[Music]
pour into a freezer-proof container stir
in a good handful of chopped fresh basil
and place covered in the freezer for
three hours
when the granita is frozen around the
edges lightly break up the mixture with
a fork
[Music]
return to the freezer and repeat twice
until the granita is frozen with a
granular texture
spoon into chilled serving glasses
garnish each with a sprig of basil
[Music]
amazingly light and refreshing lemon and
basil granita
with our granita and feta salad done and
the griddle chicken beautifully charred
we can put the final touches to our main
course
i'll take the chicken
look how juicy that is see what i want
you to do now with a basil yeah is to
get big leaves i just want to tear them
in there
there you go
start lifting the chicken up please and
putting it in the chickpeas
oh that juicy amazing chicken
remember this little baby here a
vinaigrette
the heat of the chicken will infuse the
basil because the chicken's nice and
warm
melt the basil
and turn this salad into something
really delicious that smells so nice
see how we've glazed the chicken
slide that onto our plate
how gorgeous is that
got a roasted pepper flavour
fresh basil
those wonderful chickpeas with a cape of
berries i think jack will like this one
you think jack would like this one yeah
yeah i'm megan
and tilly ready
interesting let's go
well done
[Music]
this is my ultimate light dinner
griddle chicken thighs with chickpeas
and a lemony dressing
feta and watermelon salad
and for a refreshingly zingy end to the
meal lemon and basil granita